so the energy is coming from the the
heat in my cup of coffee my cup of
coffee is getting getting colder it's
taking heat and heat out of the cup of
coffee
and the heat's going from the hot side
to the cold side and some of the energy
some of that heat energy is being
converted into mechanical energy in this
uh
in this little sterling engine here
most people when they were when they
were at school doing the gcses will
remember that work is defined as being a
force times a distance so when we want
to get a car to move along we we push it
in the direction we want it to go and by
pushing through a certain distance
that's the amount that's the work we put
into the car and then the car's got this
mechanical energy this kinetic energy as
we call it and it's and it's moving
along most of our energy comes from uh
uh comes in the form of heat we dig
fuels out the ground and burn them or we
we grow uh biomass biofuels and burn
those as well to generate heat and what
we've got to do is to convert this heat
into mechanical energy
to uh so we can drive the cars and the
planes and everything and the way we
convert heat into mechanical energy is
to use something called a heat engine
you've certainly seen one because you've
got one in your car because a petrol
engine a diesel engine a jet engine
they're all heat engines they all
convert the heat from the burning of the
fuel the diesel fuel the petrol into
mechanical energy and push your car
along
when we've got energy in the form of
heat all the atoms are are buzzing
around they're moving around it's that
heat energy is actually kinetic energy
at the atomic level but every atom is
moving around in a different direction
buzzing in different directions they've
got different amounts of energy and it's
all very mixed up and very random and
what we want to do is to create that is
to somehow
make that less mixed up and we want to
convert some of that energy into
mechanical energy where all the atoms
are moving in the same direction with
the same speed
and to do that we use we use a heat
engine and this is known as a sterling
engine but it's just one example of a
heat engine there's lots of other sorts
of heat engines like the petrol engines
and diesel engines in your car and jet
engines and so on they're all different
examples of the heat engine
it works when you have a temperature
difference so i've got a hot a hot cup
of coffee here so we'll put it on the
top and just allow
time for it to um to heat up a bit
the blue plate on the bottom
is a piece of aluminium and uh it's
being heated up by the heat from the
coffee
and uh inside there's a uh
an enclosed volume of air inside the
inside the sterling engine there are two
pistons there's a big white piston
inside the uh
inside the bottom section here and then
there's a small black piston at the top
now the big white piston is a very loose
fitting piston and um we call it a
displacer piston and all it does is
displace air from the top to the bottom
the bottom plate here is getting hot and
it's heating up that air and when air
heats up it expands and as it expands it
pushes the black piston up so you can
see the black piston coming up here like
this then what we do is the displacer
piston the white piston the big piston
we then move that down to the bottom
and when we push it down to the bottom
it it moves the air the hot air that was
in contact with the hot plate now moves
the top it starts to cool down as it
starts to cool down
it uh it shrinks and sucks this piston
back in again so this this black pistons
now moving down we should get the engine
to go around
there it is it's going around that's
high heat tension now what's happening
in this heat engine the heat's going
from hot to cold and heat naturally goes
from hot to cold but with this engine
we're actually uh we've actually
persuaded some of this disordered heat
energy to can be converted into
mechanical energy that's driving this
this wheel around so the energy is
coming from the the heat in my cup of
coffee my cup of coffee is getting
getting colder it's taking heat and heat
out of the cup of coffee
and the heat's going from the hot side
to the cold side and some of the energy
some of that heat energy is being
converted into mechanical energy in this
uh
in this little sterling engine here
for the amount of mechanical energy you
get a sterling engine will be quite big
and much and a petrol engine or a diesel
engine you get more power out of a uh
out of a the same size engine if it's a
petrol engine or a diesel engine then
you do uh after the same size sterling
engine so the reason you've got a uh
petrol engine or diesel engine in your
car is because you get more more power
out of a certain size engine it was
called a sterling engine after the guy
who invented it and he was a guy called
now i think he was he was a guy called
sterling and i think if i'm correct
remember correctly he was a clergyman in
a scottish clergyman
so the sterling engine's cooled down now
and i can we can make the sterling
engine work this time by
by making the the top surface much
colder than the surroundings so i've got
some ice cubes here
oops
so if i put an ice cube on the top
surface just here
it'll cool down the top surface
now we're still converting heat energy
into mechanical energy but this time
the the the source of heat is the desk
which is just at room temperature and
the heat is uh
the heat is
cooling down and uh to these ice cubes
and these ice cubes are melting as you
can see but the the temperature
difference that's driving this heat
engine is now the temperature difference
between the desk and the ice cubes and
you can see in fact it's going around
even faster than it did with a cup of
coffee
and you can see it's going around the
clappers
i think it's i think it's really great i
think it's a really neat
little heat engine there and it's really
quite easy to explain to people how it
uh how it works just works the hot air
expands and cold air contracts
and we've
managed to uh and the energy which
naturally wants to go from to be more
disordered we've tricked some of the
energy into becoming ordered energy and
converted into some
uh converted into mechanical work uh in
this sterling engine but people don't
expect that uh
we can convert uh we can get ice cubes
and uh
get work from ice cubes we've got
mechanical energy from ice cubes here
so maybe there's an opportunity there if
we uh
uh if we saw some icebergs
we could
uh
attach sterling engines to them and get
to
get mechanical power from icebergs